a view of the mykonos harbour known as
little venice close by are the chameleon
the five old windmills which are an
emblem of the island and a popular
snapshot motif for two million tourists
through visit mykonos each year a few of
them have stayed on thomas Heine and
Maffeo hat who came here from germany
and in 2012 opened a design hotel here
the san giorgio stands right by the sea
on para garbage about six kilometers
from the town and its crowds it blends
modern design with tradition the 33
rooms feature plenty of wood and
artifacts from the area we just wanted
to create a place where people could
feel at home or at least at their best
friends where you go and from the very
first moment you feel at ease where you
don't have to get dressed up to go to
breakfast or dinner Mykonos is famous
for its beaches more than 20 of them all
around the island
the Cyclades islands are most famous for
the clear turquoise sea all around them
super paradise beach in the south is one
of the most popular
new year everybody is just really chill
and nice and friendly so yeah I left the
five here just because I split so this
is my third time here on Mykonos and I
think I've spent most of my time on
super Paradise Beach
I'm thrilled it's different from Majorca
it doesn't have that disco in Boonton
atmosphere it has an easygoing party
mood or you can go off on your own the
islands biggest town is officially
called Mykonos but is better known as
hora the center is a maze of narrow
alleys and designer and souvenir shops
the minimalistic architecture painted
white with deep blue trim is typical of
the Greek islands no building is allowed
to be higher than two stories
Gianni's colitis was born in Mykonos in
the 1960s as a young fashion designer he
moved to the United States and made his
mark dressing stars like actress Ingrid
Bergman and the soprano Maria Callas at
that time
Mykonos was discovered by the
international jet set
today galati's has a boutique in the
town and is something of a local
celebrity himself Maria Callas so many
memories for all the famous people Melia
college with Onassis
well they arrived here I shall welcome
the world's lovely with me but when they
arrived chandra journalists and some
photography was very rude very bad not
not a way to say I don't want pictures
some people was lovely like Rita
Hayworth the traditional village of an
O'Meara in the islands interior presents
a stark contrast to the tourists havens
it's the site of the panagia trolley Ani
monastery founded by two monks in the
16th century thousands of people visit
its church every year to see the icon of
the Virgin Mary
this is the religious center of the
island and also a cultural center and a
place that played a very significant
role into the history of the island the
institution of monasticism is not just
important for the Greeks or the Greek
Orthodox world but it's important also
for all of us globally because in
libraries of monasteries like this there
were some ancient Greek manuscripts
preserved and copied by monks when the
Sun sets on Mykonos its nightlife kicks
in party goers packed the clubs one of
the trendiest is the Paradise Club
featuring DJs from around the world here
guests can dance under the open sky till
the Sun comes up again